meaning with that attack on a detention
center in Yemen who the officials say
more than 70 people are reported to have
being killed in air strikes by the
saudi-led coalition in the province of
damar now in the past few minutes the
International Red Cross said it is
estimating more than 100 people have
been killed it's expressing quotes deep
concern and is sending urgent medical
supplies and hundreds of body bags to
the scene as teams searched through the
rubble Houthi officials say the center
has people loyal to Yemen's un-backed
government I swear to god I don't know
what happened we were sleeping at
midnight and then there was about three
or four airstrikes maybe six it was
targeting the jail I really don't know
how many times had got hurt but it was
targeting a detention center in the city
of damar we were a hundred people on the
ground level and around a hundred and
fifty at the upper level and then the
Red Cross came now as we're trying to
get through to our correspondent
covering this aspect of the ongoing
conflict in Yemen let's just show you
that some of the latest pictures as is
the way with the conflict in Yemen we've
been getting a trickle-down effect of
information coming through it with
initially they thought 50 people had
been wounded that was according to a
spokesman for the Houthis Ministry of
Health Yousef al Hari has been quoted on
the Reuters news agency saying at least
60 people were killed 50 were wounded
after those air raids which hit that
complex used as a detention center north
of the city of Douma they were targeting
the jail quotes I really don't know the
strike numbers we were 100 people on the
ground level and around 150 on the upper
level now earlier a Houthi spokesman was
being quoted as saying that via Twitter
that the death toll was 50 people killed
and 100 injured that statement corrected
or I guess fine-tuned by what we're
hearing from different organizations
working in the ground a statement also
been carried on sadly state TV I noticed
the coalition saying it's launched air
raids on Houthi military targets in
damar and destroyed a site store
drones and missiles if they thought they
were going for a site storing drones and
missiles that's significant because the
Houthis have managed quite audaciously
to get occasionally has to be said over
the past what four weeks now
drone attacks well north into a line of
Saudi territory that runs parallel with
the Saudi capital Riyadh the Western
Bank coalition as we know seeing it's
taken measures to protect civilians in
Dhamma and the assault did comply with
international law quotes that's
something else we're being told as well
the location of the detention center as
we've been reporting on this program
it's known by the International
Committee of the Red Cross as well as
the coalition they are sending people
and equipment to the scene trying to
deal with the aftermath of what's going
on there the ICRC on Yemen saying that
their team is caring both urgent medical
supplies that can treat up to 100
critically injured persons and 200 body
bags to be donated that's on its way to
the province of dama following those
airstrikes which are according to the
ICRC directly off Twitter reported to
have killed or wounded dozens of dete
detainees let's talk now to Al Jazeera's
Mohamed Al Attar who's in Sanaa
Muhammad this is a fast-moving situation
what's the latest information you have
for us yes expected to rise due to the
big knock of inmates inside this prison
at least so far 60 people have been
confirmed by the Ministry of Health but
is bigger so the ICRC it's really
catastrophic and hopefully incidents
especially when they are targeted at
prison we're over 170 and they decided
they are the most of them are loyal to
the Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia claim that
we have saw the Reba claim that they
have targeted military our howdy minutes
we can but where are the four
drones and themselves but so far
when we have verified this place it's a
community college which has been turned
by the Hokies into our president this
prison has been one for the
International Red Cross and also other
international organizations so it's
coordinates have been shared with all of
the into international organizations
especially over the International Red
Cross the rights activists here in Yemen
the the confirm that what had what
happened today is a war crime that Saudi
Arabia should be held responsible for
what he has done it's not the first time
for Saudi fighter jets to target big
gatherings of civilians and win more
than one occasion funerals weddings have
been targeted the later on Saudi Arabia
explained and saying that they have
received wrong coordinates all that the
blame the yeah he had his government or
the the governments of the the
internationally recognized government
staff fall for what we have received of
coordinates but so far on the ground we
witness in the daily basis and
discriminate acts on civilians and many
international organizations including
the Human Rights Watch who revealed
their reports on the fishermen he says
he says that at least was Saudi Arabia
as targeted 46 civilians in their report
have been verified by themselves while
the number of fishermen is bigger than
that but this is the verified reports
which have been conducted by an entire
international dependent
organizations that have found out that
the saudi arabia's is responsible and
could be blamed for war crimes against
Yemenis with a fisherman or on president
like what happened okay
Mohammed just to unpack this for us for
the next minutes or so and just to be
perfectly clear we are saying that most
of the people in this building were
loyal to the saudi-led coalition it was
the saudi-led coalition that was doing
bombing of this facility therefore the
saudi-led coalition in effect has killed
several hundred of his own people
yes most of all of those we can see that
most of them are loyal to be Saudi
Arabia we have been captured by the
Houthis and battlefield Farah doodoos we
are fighting with the internationally
recognized government backed by the
Saudi Arabia so the most of them are
created to the party we can see that and
also the team party parties members have
been also attacked by the United
Emirates in Aden when they have tried to
to recapture the the city of Aden after
has fallen at the hands of the
separatists of the transitional
suffering Council forces so we are
witnessing and increasing attacks on
those who are loyal to the Saudi Arabia
and UAE Arab Emirates and many rights
activists wonder why is the Saudi Arabia
along with our lives
Sadiq targeting now the those who pose
on their side against the Houthis this
is a raise another question and also
this will will will spread her among
those who are fighting along their with
their site it's not the first time for
Saudi Arabia at like it's a prison and
in a previous occasion satisfied to just
targeted the people who are loyal to the
Saudi Arabia after the former President
Ali Abdullah Saleh in Renate from his
alliance with the Houthis along with his
when they have been captured inside the
house he prison the Saudi fighter jets
target this one oil to boot Allah Allah
and also the - to Saudi Arabia okay
Mohammed stay close we'll come back to
you as and when we get any more
information